[Música]
[Aplausos]
así la web imagen de lo que está aquí
una noche
así una buena sana sin aquí ha vuelto en
un ataque para grandísimo de en qué
guadiato excusa lo que susto te asigna
que sustenta existía un chitón humano
lionel cuéntanos las historias la
epopeya los cuentos pues le echaban las
viejas en palenque los viejos cuenta
nuestra historia de tío conejo con tea
zorra bueno
este es un puesto que pasó hace propios
tiempos según conjunción con las horas o
racks y trataban de problemas con tigres
en la selva
conejo estaba adaptado hacia el mal
siempre a tigre y tigre le dijo a
conejos porotos me siga robando porque
si me siga así vamos a tener problemas
hizo raúl díaz lengua tigre que con eso
estaba robándole y el tigre de la zorra
tu marido está haciendo daño entonces
bajas el accidente
un día salió torre dijo conejo llévame
en la rosa tuya y como le decía a zorra
que la rosa era de él
ésta lo metía el conejo ellos zorra
conejo llévame en torrox dice conejo no
no te puedo llevar porque ese hombre que
está ya critica a mis vecinos es muy
valiente y no quiere otra gente pos
trufa mil
bueno el día esté en la tarde llegó todo
con el ave las rosas
y de repente espera que todo va y me
siento hoy muy alegre no estoy en la
rosa temario pero lo ponemos barrio y
tiene el hoyo
seguirá tiene impacto en el trabajo
consigue a zorra con conejo arrancando
de la yuca la patilla y tiene dijo a
zorra para conejo pérez que no va a
quito los días porque no soy yo y tiene
de como es tan valiente del programa
facebook evalúa por heath halcones son
rajoy o pastas y tigre atraco no aguante
cuando llegó el conejo en su madriguera
en su casa se metió con los de su casa y
tira atrás tire lo agarró por un pie
[Música]
ahora el conejo tigre tú cómo quiere el
hombre más bruto este mundo tú tienes
agarrado ahora a las patas de mi cama 17
tiempos y por eso lo estamos pasando yo
los llamo los investigue y si sabor
conejo y quiero hasta ahí este puesto
muy especial para ley que es el rincón
de áfrica en colombia vale en que es el
primer pueblo libre en américa palenque
es patrimonio cultural de la humanidad
nosotros en palenque tenemos un ritual
con el que despedimos a nuestros muertos
que se llama el lumbalú es un rito
fúnebre que se hace cuando las personas
se mueren las mujeres mayores van
cantando llorando y danzando alrededor
del cadáver nosotros con el maestro
leonel torres le vamos a hacer una
muestra de cómo despedimos a los muertos
en palenque y no es fiesta
una expresión de dolor
pues
para recordar 16
bailey
o
feliz
[Música]
min
gracias
sí señor
así que se hacen acusar y susto el
palenque
ese es uno de los ritmos más
representativos para nosotros en
palenque y a raíz de ser ritmos se
desprenden mucho más después de ese
ritmo viene el bullerengue que otro
ritmo de nuestra comunidad san basilio
de palenque que se hace y tiene una gran
importancia dentro de la comunidad que
es cuando pasa a una joven de joven a
mujer como tal es un baile un ritmo
melancólico de mucha concentración
dentro de la familia de los pueblos de
todos entonces queremos compartirlo un
poco de lo que el bullerengue como tal
el ritmo para mí dentro de los ritmos de
palenque es el ritmo
a la mujer como tal con mucho respeto
para las mujeres y lo queremos compartir
para colombia y el mundo
dice así
más gente diciendo a mi imagen de ti en
la mitad
de la
amén
no no no
[Aplausos]
[Música]
civiles su papá realmente dice lo mismo
de la vida
[Música]
[Aplausos]
la tradición ni siquiera 20 cuando
misión ni siquiera mi misma gente tanto
para los trabajos
[Música]
el oro
y él a mí
lo que no está mal
con el orden los renos
o no
[Música]
así nawe maná con bueno aouate a todos a
lo que susto tan hace en colombia
existen 69 lenguas nativas dentro de
ella existen dos criollas como es el
creole en san andrés y el palenquero en
palenque nosotros somos riquezas
cultural
nosotros somos identidad nosotros
siempre hemos mantenido la raíz nosotros
ahora queremos compartirles otro de los
ritmos en palenque con los que se hacían
las fiestas como lo es la chalupa el
maestro wang nos va a cantar una chalupa
para que puedan apreciar este hermoso
ritmo que este san basilio de palenque
yo no sé ya no sé qué pasará
qué pasará
también en la caldera
ah
[Música]
javier a
[Aplausos]
el cual en que tenemos el privilegio de
tener a un gran artista como lo es el
maestro leonel torre ya que él es uno de
los pioneros en hacer terapia criolla la
terapia criolla deriva mucho de los
países de la zona occidental del áfrica
y está comprobado 100% que tenemos él
desde estos países africanos que queda
que son los hermanos de congo mali ghana
guinea bissau entonces con eso de la
mano llegó un vinilo
a la costa colombiana el norte como tal
llegó un acetato no sé si lo identifican
a un llegó a la costa y pasó por mucha
gente cívico nadie comprendía que era
hasta que llegó y dijeron no yo sé dónde
pueden comprender lo que dice la letra
de esas canciones que suenan en ese
vinilo y llegó a la mano de un
palenquero como tal y que es el ritmo se
identificó hoy día que lo que llaman el
sub highlight afrobeats y mucha
influencia de la del sur donde estamos y
donde son hoy día como tal y este señor
leonel torres
a su forma en este preso y ahí nace la
terapia criolla que lo que se ha ido
transformando y el ojo hoy día la
champeta
y ahorita le vamos a dejar con el
maestro leonel que le comparta un poco
de su música y nosotros estamos muy
agradecidos con él porque él uno de los
sabedores de nuestra cultura palin que
era como tal que queremos compartirlo y
espero que esto no se lo pide nunca que
no queda acá en este auditorio este
escenario como tal sino que le quede
para toda la vida a todos ustedes
gracias
vicente
ya todas esas hueco elena y económicas
[Música]
sí
para tanto
[Música]
[Aplausos]
oye mamones cagüán la gente habla a mis
ideas pues del congo preguntó
[Música]
d
[Aplausos]
[Música]
como tengo
y
[Música]
él estaba en la calle tomás y no todos
caben hiciste que el yoyas mientras que
en lo que tiene tomás es lo que tienes
me gustaba la tierra
[Música]
que tiene todo vale
me gustaban las 100 que le gusta la
gente le gustaba gracias a él
lo que tiene
me gustaba la tierra
[Música]
señor
gracias mi gente gracias miento
a la vida humana asina que no aouate a
un chico listo acuse a lo que sus tenga
y paraje lo que imagen de hace que te ha
visto y quién ha cundido han de américa
como lo hace para link y asina jesús
hasta en que vote andy raíz and imagen
de animan centro ahí en un atento excusa
le hablo en lengua palenquera en nuestro
dialecto
gracias
al dólar
[Aplausos]
[Música]